are investigating.
We don't know why this is just
coming to light today.
>> All right.
Gabe Cohen, thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
>>> With us now, Republican
senator Dan Sullivan of Alaska.
He's a Marine Corps veteran,
member of the reserves who
serves on the senate commerce
and armed services committee and
participated in today's hearing.
Thanks for joining us.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> Are you confident a
catastrophic meltdown like what
happened last month will not
happen again?
>> No, I'm not confident.
That's why we held a hearing.
Actually, this is the second
hearing we've held on aviation
safety and issues just in the
last two weeks on the commerce
committee.
You might remember the southwest
meltdown over the holidays.
Then the notam meltdown.
This is a big wake-up call for
our country and certainly the
FAA, and it's this -- it's old
technology.
We need to update technology to
make sure our systems are able
to function well, function
during storms like we saw over
the holidays, and make sure we
continue to have the safest
aviation travel system anywhere
in the world.
>> Is there appetite on capitol
hill to spend the money to
update the technology so that we
have the systems we need?
>> Oh, I think absolutely,
certainly from this senator you
do.
And here's the reason, Jake.
I mean, Americans take for
granted that we have, like I
said, the safest air travel of
anyplace on the planet.
It's a great record.
But what we don't want, and
we're starting to see
indications that it could
happen, we don't want
innovations and technological
advancements spurred by some
kind of major disaster.
We want to be able to be in
front of this.
To me, the signals are out there
already that we need to be
proactive, not reactive.
And I'll tell you this, in my
state, in the great state of
Alaska, boy, we need huge
upgrades to our aviation system.
We have over 250 communities
that aren't connected by roads,
and you need safe travel by air
in Alaska but across the
country.
So the answer to your question
is absolutely yes.
>> And now we're talking about
three near collisions involving
huge passenger planes.
There was one we just learned
about in Honolulu.
All of these were within a month
of each other.
Did you get answers on how this
is being addressed?
>> Well, to be honest, the news
of the third one is something
that I just learned about as
well.
But it makes the point that I've
been making, which is we need to
get in front of this.
Three warnings, three warnings,
and in addition, like I said, to
the meltdown of southwest over
the holidays, to me is a very
significant warning that we've
got to take preemptive measures,
proactive measures to make sure
we have safety.
That's why we've had two
hearings in the last two weeks
on this.
We'll continue to do it.
We also need an FAA
administrator.
You saw today the witness was an
acting administrator.
We need a full senate-confirmed
administrator soon, have the
hearings soon to press on these
issues when he goes through his
confirmation.
>> Let's urn to another issue I
know is important to you as an
alaskan.
The Chinese spy balloon.
>> Yeah.
>> The senate got a classified
briefing on China in the last
hour.
Do you think president Biden
handled this correctly, both the
spy balloon and also the three
subsequent aircraft -- had that
have been shot down from the
sky?
>> The first thing you mentioned
in Alaska.
The first thing I want to do is
a shout-out to the Alaska air
forces, National Guard.
Think about what they've done in
the last ten days.
They tracked this big balloon.
They went and intercepted it.
They tracked these smaller radar
signatures of objects.
They went and intercepted those,
shot two of those down, the one
over Alaska, the one over
Canada.
Those were alaskan base forces
that shot the Canadian one.
And just yesterday they
intercepted a bear bomb we are
two fighter escorts that was
trying to get into Alaska.
That was wo weeks of work.
Our military forces in ak ank,
which by the way is the top
cover of America, were so
critical to our nation's
defenses, they've been working
overtime.
But I will tell you this.
I've been satisfied with the
briefings I've gotten from the
military.
General van hurt, the north com
commander, has kept me well
informed on the tracking of the
object Friday.
I strongly encouraged him, by
the way, in a bipartisan manner,
to shoot that aircraft down,
which is what they ended up
doing.
But where I have not been
satisfied is the broader
administration's lack of
transparency.
There are a number of things we
learned in the briefing
yesterday that I've been aware
of that I think the American
people should know about.
And, you know, there's things
that they should let us know.
There's things they should tell
us they don't know.
Of course they shouldn't let on
to sources and methods.
But I don't think they've been
transparent enough.
As you know, when they're not
transparent, then, you know, the
wild speculation, unfounded
fears can result in the public.
They need to be more
transparent.
>> Anything you want to share
with us from the briefing?
I'm sure our viewers would love
to hear.
>> Well, look, today's briefing
was actually -- yesterday's
briefing was on the balloons.
And I pressed them to share
more, which I think is V its up
to the executive branch to do.
Today's briefing was on the
broader China threat.
It was the assessment.
It's still going on.
It's a highly classified
briefing, but I will tell you
this, it was a sobering
briefing, because our military
advantage relative to the
Chinese continues to erode.
And we need to focus on that,
and I'm calling on the president
to focus on that.
It was his administration giving
this briefing that I just walked
out of about the erosion of our
advantage relative to the
Chinese.
And each year the president
sends up a budget for defense
that's defense cuts.
And, you know, it's a huge
disconnect.
His administration is literally
telling 100 senators right now
about the challenges and the
erosion of our military
advantage, and each year they
send up cuts to the Pentagon.
Makes no sense.
And I think they need to put
forward a budget that reflects
the threats that they're
briefing senators on right now.
>> Also, U.S. Intelligence
officials are investigating the
possibility that that Chinese
spy balloon was meant to fly
over Guam, where the U.S. Has
military facilities, but instead
was blown wildly off course
because of strong winds.
What do you make of that?
>> So, again, this is what's a
little frustrating.
I've been in several classified
briefings about these spy
balloons.
I have not heard that in any of
the classified briefings.
We had briefings yesterday that
said in a classified setting
that the Pentagon and the
intelligence community was not
sure where these additional
balloons and Octobers have come
from.
I still think we should suspect
the worst, like our adversaries,
China and Russia.
And then you have right after
that briefing admiral Kirby at
the national security council
staff saying he doesn't think
it's China at all.
Again, that's a disconnect to
what 100 senators were told
yesterday, so I think they need
to get their story straight.
My understanding of that Chinese
spy balloon had propulsion to do
some directional travel, so I'm
not sure it was subject fully to
the winds, and it seemed to be
directed over Alaska and the
rest of the country in a way
that was purposeful.